this is Rana that gets people going
Chris jewel is a social trivia game that
you can play with one other person or
with a group now a Hamburg ad agency has
launched Germany's first championship
they're looking to crown Germany's
cleverest ad agency so now people are
even playing at work in design guns and
our heads on outside it's an
entertaining way to pass the time you
test your knowledge and learn a bit
along the way I think it's delightful
not even gonna show man it's fun it's
exciting and even addictive it's fun to
see if you know more than your friends
Mia bias as an appointment as definitive
I'm one of the top two million players
number 1 million nine hundred and twelve
thousand seven hundred and eighty-two to
be precise that's why my sister not bad
when you consider that there are about
six million active players in Germany
getting started is easy just download
the app and find an opponent each round
has three categories and there are 21
categories in all for every question
there are four possible answers but the
clock is ticking so you have to think
fast in the end the person with the most
correct answers wins
now over to Stockholm Sweden where the
apt inventors all live there around 30
years old and have been friends since
they were children
robert finstad Carla Landon and his
brother Allah are all fans of social
games and also enjoy computer
programming the app is no flash in the
pan the developers spent two years
trying out successful smartphone games
and then set to work on their own it was
in 2011 there was a really popular
social game and that was based on the
scrabble principle a word game and we
realized the strength in that kind of
social game and we wanted to do a
similar game but with our own twist so
that's when we came up with the idea of
a quiz game like that two weeks after
release the app was already the most
popular download in Sweden the tiny
startup is meanwhile a mid-sized company
with about 50 staff from across Europe
the staff member from Russia designs new
graphic elements that can be used to
create online identities the game has
been released in 13 countries every day
they add hundreds of new trivia
questions they all have to be translated
and adapted for each country that can be
tricky we had an example in Germany what
this trocadero and this is a question
that had been transferred from the
Swedish database and the person who
translated it probably thought that yeah
it's fine it's it would work in Germany
also but the correct answer was a soft
drink and that soft drink had apparently
never been launched in Germany so no one
know what it was so everyone guessed
that it was a tropical island quiz games
have been popular for years the Trivial
Pursuit board game was first launched in
Canada in the 1980s and went on to sell
more than 90 million times around the
world in the digital age many trivia
games have gone online there are more
than 2,000 available in app stores but
quiz jewel has by far the most fans it's
been downloaded about 23 million times
around the world its biggest fan base is
in Germany where it's been downloaded 14
million times Galvis assigned a super
storage I think there's something very
German about wanting to test your mettle
in games like this in quiz duel and you
have to rely on your knowledge and skill
like that gets you social status here
under the Germans like to be
knowledgeable and they like to
demonstrate that so trivia games like
this are perfect for us a perfect
diamond
back in the Hamburg ad agency the
Germany white jewel has gone to the next
round by the end of March the smartest
ad agency will be crowned and soon there
will even be a quiz jewel on German
television with competitors in the
studio taking on viewers at home